c'est une procédure de destitution qui a
déjà fait couler beaucoup d'encre avant
même le début du procès ce mercredi la
chef des démocrates américains nancy
pelosi a paraphé l'acte d'accusation de
la chambre des représentants
le document a ensuite été officiellement
transmis au sénat
le procès du 45e président des états
unis devrait débuter mardi prochain
donald trump devient ainsi le troisième
président de l'histoire des états unis
après andrew johnson et bill clinton à
être jugé en vue d'une destitution
c'est aujourd'hui nous rentrons dans
l'histoire nous allons écrire l'histoire
et nous allons aussi réaliser des
progrès pour le peuple américain pour
notre constitution que nous soutenons un
progrès en l'honneur du sacrifice et de
la vision de nos fondateurs progrès en
l'honneur du sacrifice de nos hommes et
de nos femmes en uniforme et progrès
pour le futur de nos enfants
faire en sorte que ce président soit
tenu responsable et que personne ne soit
au dessus des lois
nous invitons officiellement les
directeurs de la chambre à venir au
sénat jeudi à midi pour exposer leurs
articles de destitution permettront de
nous élever au dessus de l'esprit de
parti mesquin et de rendre justice à nos
institutions anoeta et à la nation nous
pouvons le faire et nous devons le faire
à l'origine de cette procédure de
destitution un appel téléphonique de
donald trump avec son homologue
ukrainien volodimir zelensky au cours
duquel le président américain avait
demandé l'ouverture d' enquête visant
ses opposants politiques accusés depuis
d'abus de pouvoir et d entrave à la
bonne marche du congrès donald trump n'a
pas manqué de réagir sur twitter
nous y voici une autre arnaque
orchestrée par les démocrates qui ne
font rien tout ce travail était censé
être fait par la chambre pas par le
sénat des sénateurs américains qui ont
justement prêté serment ce jeudi devant
le chef de la cour suprême qui présidera
le procès et républicains et démocrates
doivent ainsi déterminer la liste des
témoins qui seront auditionnés au sénat
avec 53 sièges sur 100 la majorité
républicaine semble présager un
acquittement de donald trump
une majorité de deux tiers est
nécessaire pour destituer le président
pourtant les démocrates espèrent faire
émerger de nouveaux éléments contre ces
derniers et réclament l'audition de
quatre proches conseillers de donald
trump
selon un haut responsable de
l'administration du président américain
le procès ne devrait pas durer plus de
deux semaines un délai suffisant pour
donald trump afin de se concentrer sur
sa campagne de réélection
[Musique]